that vaccine rollout it is ramping up
today in a big big way
health care workers got their first
shots yesterday many after months on the
front lines today
hundreds more sites will receive the
vaccine as part of a massive operation
that hopefully just hopefully will
eventually end this pandemic
it's a huge cause for hope at a time of
great suffering in this country the
american death toll has now passed 300
000 since the pandemic began and
consider this the u.s has around 4
percent of the world's population
but more than 18 percent of the dead
tied to the coronavirus
our lead national correspondent david
begno is at uc davis medical center
that's in sacramento
david good morning to you tony good
morning listen i've referred to this as
the super bowl of medicine but not
everybody gets to play on day one
so there's a second day and that's
what's happening around the country
today uc davis and other health
institutions will get
their shipment and you know when it
arrives the pfizer vaccine is frozen
so we've asked nurse mary rose and rn
here who's been treating frontline
patients and will get the vaccines
to show us what reconstitute means she
just took saline
out of a bottle she will now inject it
in what will be a vial of the vaccine
when it arrives
you get the saline with the vaccine you
mix it up
and you are ready to go doesn't take
long and that's what's happening
at health institutions around the
country
okay little poke one two three these
were the shots seen across america
from the first nurse in queens new york
to california
frontline workers are leading the way
yet again
receiving doses of pfizer's coronavirus
vaccine
dr malicia cumberland was the first
person vaccinated at her hospital in
connecticut
do you have any symptoms after the shot
no outside of some
regular you know when you get a shot you
have that soreness in your arm
that's it nothing else dr cumberland
says she's aware of the public's
concerns
and admits she was also a little
hesitant at one point
i'm proud of myself for doing it proud
of yourself why
because i was selfless i did it to make
sure
that yes you know i'm safe but i did it
to start to
almost build trust within our community
and to really say
you know we trust science to west
virginia now
governor jim justice became one of the
first elected officials to be injected
he said he wanted to build public
confidence in its safety
141 sites received shipments on monday
and the government plans to deliver 2.9
million doses
to 636 locations this week
now u.s leaders want to vaccinate about
50 million people
by february reaching that number will
also depend on the fda's approval of the
moderna vaccine
which could be available for
distribution as early as next week
we have enough vaccines already
purchased to ensure we can meet our goal
of vaccinating every american who wants
it by the end of the second quarter of
2021.
back to dr cumberland she says she could
not be more proud
to be a part of this historic moment
the legacy i want to leave is that i
gave myself
to let people know that they are safe
i gave myself so that someone else
is healed cured and they find peace of
mind
and what a legacy dr cumberland listen
when you get pfizer's vaccine you get a
card like this to remind you
the date you got the vaccine and that
you need to get a second one
in order to be complete that's for
pfizer's vaccine
the race to find out when the vaccine is
getting here is like
waiting for your gifts on christmas
morning chad's the chief pharmacist uh
what's the delivery expected to be
this morning this morning this morning
is it already in sacramento it is in
sacramento they've been tracking it all
the way
from memphis gail this morning it
arrives i know we saw
chad yesterday looking at that same
machine but i love how you showed
how mary rose took us through the
process of how it all works i think
that's very interesting
just to let us know every step quickly
easy yeah exactly how it goes david
thank you very much